[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So let
me catch us all back up.
We have one more week of classes
consisting of two lectures.
They're pretty exciting
because in effect, everything
comes together at the end.
The one today is the failure
of the welfare theorems,
but not just that a
theorem doesn't work,
but why it doesn't
work and also remedies
that are going to make its way
into proposals for new market
structures that get rid
of the externalities,
existing and new.
And then the one on Thursday
is on monetary theory
where we will actually have
money and cryptocurrency
in the model.
And we can address things like
the price of Bitcoin, which
yesterday hit an
all-time record,
but I haven't
looked at it today.
And that's kind of the point.
So on the reading list, today
is Failure of the Well Welfare
Theorems.
There's two starred
articles here.
It's a little bit unconventional
relative to other lectures
in the sense that I'm not going
to cover either one of these
in enormous amount of detail,
and yet they are a starred.
So it's fair game
in terms of things
that I expect you to know.
I only have four or
five slides at the end
on the Jain-Townsend paper, but
it relates to cryptocurrency
and platforms for exchange.
So it is very consistent
with some of the themes
we keep hitting
on in the course.
And this Arrow article, very
famous one, I have only today
extracted two or three--
really two slides from a
much larger and much more
interesting paper.
So take a look at those.
Are there-- before
I ask you all,
are there any questions
from last time,
about the lecture
from last time?
So last time was identification
and falsification with data.
There is a question that's
actually not written down here,
but I feel I want to ask anyway.
Namely, what was the
point of the lecture?
Why do we care about being able
to falsify a model with data?
And I'll take volunteers.
Why is it important to be
able to reject a model?
STUDENT: I mean, I guess
it makes it more testable.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well--
STUDENT: If we have
empirical data,
we can tell whether it's
even feasible for it
to be that model.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, yeah.
That's good.
Or a more brutal way to put it
is, if it's not falsifiable,
then it can't be rejected.
And if it can't
be rejected, what
is the point of taking it to
the data in the first place?
That's a little bit
harsh in the sense
that you could accept the
model as an abstract version
of reality, use it to
estimate parameters,
conduct policy
experiments-- and we
did that several times in the
lectures on trade and so on.
But this lecture embraces the
full empirical experimental
science point of
view that we want
to make some progress
by ruling things out.
So you really want to if you're
in the wrong class of models.
And the way to do
that is to at least
have the possibility
of data that
would be inconsistent with the
model so that you would know.
OK.
So that wasn't asked.
Thank you for
volunteering an answer.
So apropos along
that line, how do we
test whether an observed
demand function came
from a consumer-maximizing
utility?
Or I guess more
specifically, does anyone
remember one, two, or all
three of the implications that
come from the premise of
consumer optimization for data?
STUDENT: It should have
homogeneity of degree 0.
It has to satisfy while
reaching equilibrium.
And the Slutsky matrix has
to be symmetric and negative
[INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I'm not
actually hearing you very well.
Can you repeat that?
STUDENT: Oh yeah.
The demand function has to
be homogeneous of degree 0.
It has to satisfy while
reaching equilibrium.
And the Slutsky matrix has to be
negative, [? semi-definite. ?]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, perfect.
So satisfy-- I guess
we call it Walras' law,
but essentially means
that they're spending
all their money and they're not
in the interior of the budget
set.
And yeah, homogeneity of degree
0, no inflation illusions.
And the Slutsky
thing is the thing
we derived pretty
carefully the last time.
Does anyone remember what--
and can state the weak axiom
of revealed preference?
STUDENT: Let's say we have
two pairs of observations
containing prices and
consumption bundles.
And for example, for like p,
p2, the x2 is preferred over x1.
And then for p1, the x2
should be outside of budget.
Otherwise, x1 would not
be preferred under p1.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yep.
Yeah, you said it right I
think except for the very end.
We start with two pairs,
p2x2 and p1x1, and--
so maybe I have it here.
I'm not finding
the slide I wanted
that I thought was going to
be right in front of me, but--
STUDENT: It's in a
previous page, the--
yeah, yeah.
It was just a statement, yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So we
have these two pairs
and they're not the same, so
there's a real experiment here.
And we start with
the second pair.
Under prices p2, they choose x2.
They could have chosen
x1, but did not.
because x1 is in the budget
and they did not.
So they revealed to
prefer x2, quote-unquote.
But if that's true,
then when at price is p1
when they're choosing x1,
x2 should not be available.
Because if it were
available at prices p1,
having already deduced
that x2 is preferred to x1,
they would likewise choose
x2 in that situation and that
would be a contradiction.
So thank you, yeah,
you said it fine.
OK.
So again, those
are just sample--
somewhat not-so-randomly-sampled
questions,
but there are others
there I could have asked.
I was tempted to go over
the thing about the Slutsky
matrix again and the concavity
of the expenditure function
and so on, but I--
and how we end up being able
to deduce restrictions on data
from the Hicksian demand
which we don't observe.
But anyway, I didn't ask.
So OK.
So that's-- oh.
And then the one
other thing, which
is actually the reason
I had this open--
wow.
I'm having trouble
manipulating the slide deck.
This Echenique.
So one of you asked me last
time, I guess in my office hour
on Thursday, what's
going on here?
It's actually all on the slide.
I took the time this morning
to look up the paper on the--
I don't have the book.
The book is in my
MIT econ office
and I have been in
there for nine months.
But portions of the
paper are online.
And it's algorithmic
and just saying,
if you have the data, like
the kind of data we have in
revealed preference--
so we see prices and quantities
and we're trying to--
in integrability, we're
trying to deduce the utility
function or a utility function
that would generate the data.
So the issue is, if
you had a utility
function the household
would be maximizing
it to generate
the data, how hard
is it to maximize
the utility function?
And the spirit of
this was, there
may be a whole set
of utility functions.
There may be some
that would generate
the data for which
it would be actually
hard to compute the solution.
Like Lagrangians are
iterating over possibilities
and taking local derivatives
and so on and so forth.
When you only have a couple
of commodities and so on,
it's obvious graphically
what the maximum is.
But in higher dimensional
spaces, it's not so obvious.
And the point of
this article was
only to say that if you
choose a utility function that
is consistent with the data
that is hard to compute,
there's another one that would
generate the same data that
for which the
algorithm increases
in complexity as a polynomial
with the number of goods.
So it's definitely what you
would have thought all along.
It's a computer science
paper about algorithms.
And to get in into it
in any more detail,
one would actually have
to look at the algorithm
and deduce why it's
only increasing
in polynomial complexity.
Anyway, I just wanted to
clarify that since one of you
asked me this last time.
OK.
So for today, the failure
of the welfare theorems.
Sounds ominous.
OK.
So here's an outline
of the lecture.
We'll do failure of the
second welfare theorem
first, because ironically,
it's kind of easier.
Then we'll go to failure of the
first welfare theorem, which
is harder in some sense
because it's so easy for it
to be satisfied,
but will feature
local satiation
which violates one
of the sufficient assumptions.
And then when other reasons for
failure of the welfare theorem
have to do with
incomplete markets
where there is not a
market in every good.
Pollution is an example of
that, and you may or may not
be aware of markets
for pollution rights
as in cap and trade, and
I'll go through that.
The generalization of
that is when households
are altruistic about each
other or jealous of each other,
they really care about what
other households are consuming
in a positive or
negative way, that
generates another externality,
but in that Arrow article,
there is a way to
solve the problem,
by creating markets
for the missing goods.
Then I'll get into another
failure of the welfare theorem.
Go through the
proof that we used
and show you where it
could fail if there's
an infinite number of goods,
which brings us to overlapping
generations, nobody
lives forever,
but the economy hopefully
goes on forever.
And we have money
in the economy.
So that will take us to
the lecture next Thursday.
And finally, I want
to touch bases again
on these platforms for trading
cryptocurrency or anything
else for that matter,
which seem to be very far
away from the welfare theorems
and the frameworks we're using.
It looks like there's
an externality again.
And the theorem ought
to fail, but I'll
show you how to design
those markets in such a way
as to recover optimality.
So at that point, we
kind of crossed the line
from positive to
normative economics.
We're using economic science
to advise policymakers
on what to do.
So here's a statement of
the second welfare theorem,
which is literally pasted
in from earlier lectures.
So you know everything
on this slide.
An economy consists
of consumption sets
and preferences and
endowments, production assets,
ownership shares.
And for the second
welfare theorem,
we kind of needed a lot.
We needed convexity of
the consumption sets,
we needed the production
sets to be convex and admit
this concave transformation.
Preferences, also concave,
locally non-satiated.
And these kinds of interior
points, so to speak.
And then we have a
statement of the theorem
that for any lambda, hence,
for any Pareto optimum,
there exists a price vector and
an assignment of wealth that
would constitute a Walrasian
equilibrium with transfers
with those wealth assignments.
So the lecture where we went
through this featured two ways
to attack the problem.
One, the Lagrangian problem
both for the Pareto problem
with the lambda weights and for
each of the firm and household
maximization
problems, then we just
matched up all the
Lagrange multipliers,
but that's that only work--
typically only works for sure
if you have all this convexity
and concavity.
And the second way we did it was
just separating and supporting
hyperplane theorem which,
in turn, relied on concavity
or convexity of the steps.
So on that note, here's an
illustration when it works,
suppose you had a single
representative consumer,
this could be our Gorman man,
maximizing utility subject
to production possibility
set-- and this is obviously
the overall maximum.
So then we can create
this budget line
for the household
and a isoprofit line
for the producer which
separates these two convex
sets, the production set
from the weak upper contour
set of bundles that give
you at least as much utility
as that this red dot.
What if preferences
were not convex?
So we have a nice pink convex
production possibilities set,
but this is an
illustrative indifference
curve with all these waves.
So it has concave,
but convex portions.
Or alternatively,
the upper contour set
of utility points
which are greater
than or equal to the utility
achieved at the red dot, that's
not a convex set as
you can see by taking
say these two points in the blue
set in a weighted combination
of those two points would
not be in the blue set.
Another way to say that is
at this budget line, which
separated on the previous
slide, would not separate here,
because although we have
profit maximization,
we do not have
utility maximization,
and you can imagine
doing better here,
say, a tangency that would
achieve a higher level
of utility than a red dot.
So the second welfare
theorem would fail.
This is a competitive
equilibrium,
but it's not Pareto optimum.
Over here, we have
non-convexity of the technology.
So the upper contour
set is convex,
but you see these
non-concave portions.
So there's not a
concave transformation
representing this production
possibility set of-- production
possibility set is not convex.
So again, the
candidate here would
be the budget line for
the household for which we
have utility maximization.
At that budget line, we would
not have profit maximization
because the producer
could be doing better.
I think I misstated
the result over here.
We have a Pareto optimum.
In the second welfare
theorem we start
with Pareto optimal points.
And then we're trying
to decentralize it.
In this case, we would
have profit maximization,
but we would not have
utility maximization.
In this case, we would have
utility maximization but not
profit maximization.
So these are perfectly
fine Pareto-optimal points,
they're just not decentralizable
and the second welfare theorem
fails.
Now it doesn't just because
we don't have the convexity
doesn't mean it always fails.
This is illustrative.
I've shown you this
picture before.
We have this upper contour
set with various wiggles in it
and the production possibility
set with portions of increasing
returns, but nevertheless, at
this optimum and the associated
supporting hyperplane, we
would have utility maximization
and profit maximization.
So we might get lucky even
with the non-convexities,
but it's just not guaranteed.
Those assumptions in the
second welfare theorem
are sufficient
assumptions, not necessary.
First welfare theorem.
And again, I've kind
of, quote-unquote,
just pasted in this
slide, let's start
with a price equilibrium
with transfers,
including, say,
Walrasian equilibrium
with x star, y star, p, and w.
And then if preferences
are rational
and locally non-satiated,
x star is a Pareto optimum.
That's the theorem.
Start with a
competitive equilibrium,
it will be Pareto optimum
if it's sufficient--
that is to say, to have
rational locally non-satiated
preferences.
I remember in presenting
this, I emphasized
how weak the assumptions were,
because you might think they're
always satisfied, hence,
every competitive equilibrium
or equilibrium with transfers
would be Pareto-optimal.
However, I'll show you a
picture of where it's violated
and we're going to
pick on this local--
I'm going to show you an
example of locally-satiated
preferences, and hence, failure
the first welfare theorem,
and here we are.
So this is the Edgeworth box.
One household's over
here in the southwest
another here in the northeast.
Southwest one's easy
to see what's going on.
There's an endowment
point, the budget line
runs through the
endowment point.
This household southwest
is maximizing utility
according to the red
indifference curves
and has achieved the highest
possible utility level
within his or her budget set.
Household over here, northeast,
has indifference curves
that are, in general,
monotone-increasing
as you move southwest.
However this
shaded-in blue region
is the region of
local satiation.
So the idea is that that
household has an indifference
band, indifference curve
band, not just curves,
but this whole
interval of points
are such that the
utility level is
the same for this
northeastern household.
And maybe just in that region,
maybe the rest doesn't matter.
OK, so what's the
first welfare theorem?
It says that the competitive
equilibrium is optimal.
Here's the competitive
equilibrium.
Household southwest is
certainly maximizing utility.
Household northeast
is maximizing utility
because this point gives
at least as much utility
and maybe more than any other
point in household's northeast
budget set in this whole region.
So it is a competitive
equilibrium.
But is it Pareto-optimal?
No.
Why?
Because we could move in
this northeast direction
and increase the utility
of the southwest household
without hurting the utility
of the northeast household.
So there you go.
That's an illustration.
So we definitely use
implicitly this assumption
about local non-satiation.
And I could have
drawn pictures that
had to do with discrete points
and consumption sets which
also violates local satiation
because there's nothing nearby.
OK, so let me go back.
Another thing that's
easy to forget
in this definition of an economy
and the associated welfare
theorems is we have L goods,
say, finite dimensional,
and households have
endowment and preferences
over consumption for each
and every item in that L
dimensional space.
So when we're coming
up with these prices p,
we're pricing each
and every commodity
in the entire commodity space.
Another language we could use is
incomplete markets rather than
complete markets.
There could be items that
households care about
and that firms can produce for
which there is no price system.
You can't trade it.
And that will also cause the
first welfare theorem to fail.
So I'm going to give you a
well-known example, which
is pollution.
So in the example there are
two goods, one representative
consumer, and one firm.
The firm can transform
one of the goods, good 1,
into the second good, good 2,
according to this production
function.
And remember, for firms,
inputs are negative.
So minus y1 is the
positive quantity
of the input of the first good
mapped through the production
function F to the output
of the second good.
Now the idea here is that
the firm generates pollution
when it produces a second good.
The act of transforming
good 1 to good 2
produces this level of
pollution, but for the minute
we're not going to have
a market in pollution.
It's a genuine good--
actually, a bad, but for
the moment no prices on it.
Preferences and production
both specify this bad pollution
good.
Households care about their
consumption of good 1, good 2,
but also this pollution
P. And I should have said,
down here in red, consumer 1
begins with 1 unit of good 1
and no units of good 2.
So if the consumer is going
to get a hold of good 2,
it has to come from
firms producing it
with the input
surrendered by good--
of the household of
good 1 as an input.
OK.
So the utility
maximization problem
is just maximized
consumption of good 1
and good 2 with the fallout
that there's pollution, P,
as a consequence of y2.
y2, the second good is exactly
what the consumer is eating,
but y2 comes from
production using
the input of the first good.
And the input of the first
good, being negative,
subtracts off from
the unit endowment
that the household
has of that good,
the residual being household's
consumption of good 1.
OK, so this is like
our Pareto problem
with a couple of simplifications
and one complication.
There's only one household, no
need for the lambda weights.
You can think of this as a
Gorman person if you want.
And there's only one
firm, although we've
done that before.
And now we've had we have
this non-traded good,
this pollution aspect jointly
produced along with y2.
OK.
So this is a Pareto problem.
So I'm about to determine--
characterize the set of all
Pareto-optimal allocations.
We do that by maximizing
utility subject to effectively
the production set and
the resource constraints.
I've lined up the Lagrange
multipliers on equations 5, 6,
and 7 and ordered them 1, 2, 3.
So those are the gammas,
those are the shadow prices.
OK so everything's
convex in this world.
So we can do the
first-order conditions
for the Lagrangian
differentiating with respect
to x1, x2; consumption
for the households,
y1 and y2, inputs and
outputs for the firm.
You can check me.
At this point, you should be
familiar with the Lagrangians.
You may want to go
back and review it.
The only subtlety here is
to get the signs right.
When we write down
these constraints,
we should write them as greater
than or equal to inequalities
so that we get the interpretable
sign on the shadow prices.
Well, they should
look kind of familiar.
This says the marginal utility
of good 1 is equal to lambda 1.
The marginal utility of
good 2 equal to lambda 2.
And the household's
utility function.
This is a statement about the
marginal product of good 1
in production.
And this is a statement
about how the Lagrangian is
changing as we change y2.
Here and only here you can
see that the Pareto optimum
is taking into account
the extent to which
pollution is created
by production.
And if you go back and look
over here, the y2 is written--
P is pollution written
as a function of y2.
So when we differentiate
with respect to y2,
we pick up that partial P,
partial y2 in the household's
utility function.
And of course, we pick up y2
and the two other spots where
it enters in equation 6 and 7.
So that's where this
thing is coming from.
OK, so the rest is algebra.
You can see that we could
solve for the inverse.
If we took df to dy1 and set it
equal to lambda 1 over lambda
3, we could then go over here
and find lambda 3 and lambda 1
and make some substitutions.
Actually, we flipped
it upside-down.
Instead of df dy1,
we take 1 over that,
but we do go and look for
those substitutions, which
would be gamma 3, which
picks up this mess over here,
and gamma 1, which
picks up this guy.
So that's the algebra
behind this expression.
OK, so let's interpret it.
The marginal rate of
substitution for the household
had a Pareto-optimal allocation.
And here, we kind of do
something unconventional.
This is the marginal rate
of substitution of good 2
for good 1 and not
the other way around.
Normally if you go back and
look at the consumer lecture 2,
I guess it was, we had the
marginal rate of substitution
of good 1 for good
2 being u1 over u2.
And also the price ratio
we'll get to being P1 over P2.
So here, it's kind of
flipped the other way around.
It's not wrong, you
just gotta remember,
we're redefining the
marginal rate of substitution
to be the opposite of
what we did before.
OK.
So the marginal rate of
substitution for the household
is the marginal
utility of good 2,
marginal utility divided by
the marginal utility of good 1,
but this is equal to, from this
expression, the first part,
numerator-denominator plus
numerator-denominator.
So this plus part
numerator-denominator is here,
it's just rewritten.
So this is the full
characterization
of the Pareto-optimal
allocation.
And it kind of looks like the
marginal rate of substitution
for the consumer is
equal to something
having to do with
the marginal product
or marginal rate of
transformation in production,
but we have this extra
term and this extra term
reflects the fact
that to produce y2,
in order for the
household to get it,
x1 gets surrendered, put
in the production function,
but it also produces pollution.
So we're taking into account--
subtracting, as it were,
the bad thing that happens, the
extra pollution that happens
as a consequence of producing
good 2 which generates
pollution P. I'm not taking
you through all the--
I'm probably taking you through
too much of the algebra.
You've got to be careful
about these signs, negative
versus positive.
I was just pondering
that, but you were just
subtracting the P's
from the left-hand side.
OK.
You can check the algebra later.
Now we want to
decentralize this optimum
like we've been doing before
in the first welfare theorem.
But we're going to
do it in two steps.
In the first step, we have
a market in the two goods,
but not in pollution.
So the firm would
maximize profits.
Let's assume that the price
of the first good, good 1,
is the numeraire.
So I'm not going to
be writing p1 anymore,
but I will be writing p2.
So this is the price of
good 2 relative to good 1
because a good one
is the numeraire.
This is the output, this
is the revenue of the firm.
This is the input cost.
p1 to y1.
y1 is negative, that's
why it's being subtracted.
Subject to this
transformation set which
we've talked about before.
Now I'm going to
make a substitution.
If y2 is F of minus y1, then
take the inverse function,
F inverse on both sides,
and we get F inverse of y2
equals minus y1.
Multiply it by a minus sign
and we get y1 equal minus F1
inverse of y2.
So I'm going to substitute
this expression into this term
y1 in the objective-- in the
profit objective function.
Then when we
differentiate with respect
to how much y2 to
produce, we've already
taken into account the amount
of x1 that has to be higher
to get there.
The derivative of
this whole expression
is going to be p for the first
term, that's the revenue,
and then the derivative
of the second term, which
is how this inverse production
function is changing
as we change y2.
It is the inverse function,
but there's an inverse function
theorem which you
may not remember,
which is the derivative
of the inverse function is
1 over the derivative
of the direct function.
So this is the derivative of
the direct function mapping
input y1 into y2.
So in a competitive
equilibrium, we
get exactly what I was
alluding to before,
that the marginal rate of--
well, I haven't said it yet.
The marginal revenue product
of a good 1 into production
is equal to its price.
And it's also going to be
true that this price is going
to be equal, from the consumer
side you'll see momentarily
right here, equal to the
marginal rate of substitution
in utility terms
for the household.
So it looks like you
get the right thing
when you decentralize it,
that the marginal rate
of substitution is equal to the
rate of product transformation,
but it won't be the right
thing because it's neglecting
the indirect impact on
pollution from using
good 1 in production.
Here's the other half of
the Walrasian definition.
This is the household's
maximization problem.
To maximize utility,
including acknowledging
the disutility of
pollution subject to having
1 unit of good 1 valued at p1
equal to 1 plus the profits--
this profit-- that the firm
produces that's handed back
lump sum to the household.
We only have one
household, one firm.
This household has
complete ownership share
of profits of the firm.
And we get this
first-order conditions,
which is what I've said.
The marginal rate
of substitution
is equal to the price ratio.
So then if we take 11 and
go back and remember 10,
10 was this thing from
production, and substitute in,
we'll say the marginal rate of
substitution in an equilibrium
is equal to the marginal rate
of product transformation,
but that rate of
product transformation
is less than what you
would get if you take
the marginal rate
of transformation
and add on a positive term.
It may not be obvious
in the algebra
right away that this
term is positive,
but it is, because the marginal
utility is decreasing with P.
So this is a negative object.
And you've got a
minus sign here.
So negative-negative
equals positive.
This whole thing
is a positive term,
so that's why we have
this strict inequality.
This thing on the right-hand
side, though, is, as I said,
from 10, the marginal rate of
substitution under the optimum,
this guy here.
Actually, it was 8.
We used 10 to get this.
So the conclusion is the
competitive equilibrium
is not Pareto-optimal,
because we
want this expression
to hold as an equality,
it's holding as in inequality.
OK.
So by the way, here's
the economic intuition
for what's going on.
This marginal rate of
substitution is too small.
How do we get it to be bigger?
We'd like to increase
the numerator.
How do you get the marginal
utility with respect
to good 2 be higher?
Less of good 2.
And/or get the
denominator to be smaller,
that would also make the
marginal rate of substitution
higher.
How do you get marginal utility
of good 1 to be smaller?
Increase x1.
So the economics
here is telling us we
want to take the
competitive equilibrium
and move to the direction
of increasing x1,
eat it rather than
use it as an input
to produce x2 of which
we have too much.
So it's intuitive
in the economics
that if you don't have a
market in the pollution rights,
you're going to have
too much pollution.
But we can fix it by having
the pollution rights.
So what do I mean by that?
Suppose the household can sell
rights to pollute to the firm
and that we can enforce
those rights in the sense
that if the firm doesn't
have the rights, then
it can't pollute.
The rights will specify the
number of units of P. Firms
are going to have
to buy those rights.
It comes with y2.
So the level of P
that comes from y2
has to be consistent
with the rights
that the firm purchases, and
likewise, consistent at a price
of rights--
with the rights
that the household
is willing to surrender.
The household is
going to get revenue
from selling the rights
to pollute to the firms.
So that's a positive thing.
But on the other
hand, the household
knows that the firm will
produce with those rights
and it will suffer
that pollution.
So there's a trade-off
for the household,
but this is the
right trade-off now,
because we have the market
for the pollution rights.
OK.
In notation, we
maximize the utility
of the household over the two
goods, x1, x2, and pollution
level P bar subject to the
budget, which is get revenue
from selling your
endowment of good 1,
you get profits from the firm.
You also get revenue from
selling pollution rights
to the firm, the price
being q, the per-unit price.
Per unit of pollution is q.
First time we've used that.
And if you look at the
solution to this problem
through Lagrangian's,
we now have three goods,
good 1, good 2, and p, p bar.
If you thought about mu
as the Lagrange multiplier
on this budget constraint
12, you get the obvious
that the marginal
utilities of the goods
are equal to the marginal
utility of income
times the price.
Again, p1 is equal
to 1, so there's
no price in the first term.
Third term is kind
of interesting,
because it's got
a negative sign.
But again, pollution
is a bad from the point
of view of the household.
So this marginal
utility is negative,
the negative sign
makes it positive.
Positive equal positive.
The marginal utility
of reducing pollution
is equal to the marginal
utility of income times
the price of pollution rights.
So now in an equilibrium,
we've got the marginal rate
of substitution
over the two goods
from the household point
of view equal to p.
We could also look at the
marginal rate of substitution
of good 1 for pollution P--
P bar, actually, in
the household problem,
and that's equal to q.
So we have three goods
and we have two ratios.
For the firm's problem, they're
going to maximize profits.
This is revenue.
This is costs.
They have to buy
those rights, same q.
And rights are an input.
So we put a negative sign
here, because they've
got to buy them as an
input, the way we've
been signing inputs all along.
And anyway, it's a cost,
so it makes a lot of sense.
So we rewrite this
problem, substituting
in this inverse function for
y1, and take derivatives,
and we get, with respect
to y1, where does it enter?
It enters here and here.
y1-- I should have said y2.
By making the substitution, we
don't have y1 in the expression
anymore.
We have y2 in terms
of revenue in y2
in terms of production and
the associated pollution.
So then just manipulating
this equation--
well, sorry, looking at
the first-order condition
we get this thing, which
is the marginal revenue
on the left-hand side and
the derivative of these two
terms on the right-hand side.
And now we can go
back and do our checks
of the first-order condition.
The marginal rate of
substitution for households
of the two goods is p.
The p is equal to
this thing from 14.
So substituted in, leave
the first term the same,
and then find the
expression for q
up here from the
consumer's problem,
and keep writing dP dy2.
So that's the algebra.
And now, guess what?
We've got a full optimum.
This is exactly the
expression we wanted over
here in the full
optimum problem, not
the decentralize problem,
but in the optimum problem.
The marginal rate
of substitution
is equal to the
rates of production
taking into account pollution
and the adverse utility
consequences of pollution.
This equation 8 is exactly
what we just derived here
at the bottom of this slide.
So we've achieved it,
but we achieved it
by creating the missing market,
which was, in this case,
was pollution.
So OK, so there's a
general lesson here.
Now you may have heard
of pollution rights
before under the
terminology cap and trade.
So that's kind of related.
Particularly you let firms
pollute all they want,
but they have to buy
the rights to do it.
So you-- maybe endow firms
with arbitrary assignments
of rights, and amazingly,
it's not going to matter who--
it's not going to matter for
production who is initially
assigned a high right
to pollute and who's
assigned a low right
to produce and pollute.
And then you'll see that now.
So we have the two
firms, call them a and b.
They're both endowed with
pollution rights, Pa bar and Pb
bar.
And then we look at
the profit maximization
problem of each firm j.
To produce revenue from
output less the input required
of good 1, that's
this inverse function,
which is what we've been
doing before, except now we
have a j everywhere--
this is firm type j.
And then we have
this revenue or cost.
Q is the price of
pollution rights,
they're endowed with
pollution rights, P bar.
So we could stop there and
just say they get that revenue.
But not if they're
producing, because they
need to have the rights
corresponding to the amount
of y2 that they're producing.
So we subtract off the
corresponding rights
that they need for a
chosen level of output y2.
This term could be--
the whole term could be
positive or negative.
If they're overly endowed with
rights, they'll be selling some
and be left with a
positive residual term.
If they're underendowed
with rights,
they will be buying more rights
than they were endowed with.
But the economics is the same.
Regardless of what
the P bar is, you
want to evaluate the
price of the permits
as an opportunity cost.
That is to say, take the
case where they're overly
endowed with rights,
they could hoard them,
and then they could effectively
sell them in the market.
That would be fine.
Or they could use them up.
So the opportunity
cost of using it up
is what they could
have done with it,
which is just sell it outright.
So this opportunity
cost argument
works for both types of firms.
And it is the logic of why
the endowments don't matter.
What matters is what
they do on the margin.
That's what they take under
consideration when they're
thinking about production.
A way to see that in
the algebra is just
to take the derivative of these
profit statements for each firm
j with respect to the
choice variable y2,
taking into account
that pollution is also
a function of y2, and
we would get, again,
the derivative with respect
to the revenue with p minus--
or put it on the
right-hand side,
the derivative of production
through the 1 over the direct
inverse--
the derivative of the
direct production function,
making that substitution plus q
times the way pollution rights
are changing--
pollution permit
requirements are changing
as we're changing production.
OK.
So this equation 16 holds for
both firms j of type a or b.
Can we see who's polluting more?
Well, let's suppose that this
coal mine in West Virginia
has really bad
consequences for pollution
as opposed to something
using clean energy.
The marginal effect of
pollution is higher for type
a firms relative
to type b firms.
But if this term is
higher for a than for b,
and for both a and
b, whatever else
is going on the right-hand side,
the two terms have to sum up
to p, then for a, if this
is higher, q is the same,
this term has to be lower.
How do we get for a firms
this term to be lower?
We make the marginal
product of the input higher.
How do we do that?
We do that by
reducing the input.
So again, the
economics make sense.
The firm that-- type
that pollutes the most
will use less of the input
and therefore pollute less.
So this is another example
of pollution rights
and maybe a more familiar
one, which is cap and trade.
Which, I think you know,
is implemented in the US.
California has various kinds
of permits for polluting
and so on.
They were increasingly
popular and then things
happened over the
last four years,
but we won't go into that.
OK.
Walrasian equilibrium
with pollution rights.
So there's a more
general idea here,
which is that be externalities
all over the place.
Households can care
positively or negatively
about what other
households are eating.
Households could care about what
firms are producing-- you just
saw an example of that.
So the consumption set would
be the standard one over the L
dimensional commodity
space, but in addition, it
would specify what other
households are eating
of each of the goods over
all the other households,
i minus 1 households.
And again, what
the firm is doing.
Or if they're j firms, what
each and every one of them
is doing potentially.
Not everything
needs to be in here,
but this is--
externalities written down
in its most general form.
OK.
So we did a version of this
just now with pollution,
and we can do a version
with consumption.
So this is that part of
Arrow I was mentioning when
we went over the reading list.
We have a pure exchange economy
to make it a bit easier.
We have the usual.
Household cares about
consumption good k.
There are n households.
So i goes from 1 to n.
There are m consumer goods,
so k goes from 1 to m.
So this part so far
is pretty standard.
However, suppose that
the utility function
of the household depends on
the consumption of the others.
So if we started
with household j,
for example, if they
could choose it,
this would be the rights
to eat that j would assign
to household i for commodity k.
In other words, household j
cares about what household
i is doing.
We're going to try
to decentralize this.
So we want to create a
market in those rights.
Mathematically we're just
adding another subscript
and you have to memorize
that it goes what j wants
to assign to i for commodity k.
Well, that's household
j, here's household i.
It's the same thing.
Household has
utility function Ui
over what i wants to
assign of the first good
for the first household
all the way up
to what i wants to assign
for the n-th household
of the m-th good.
So this is a great,
big, long vector
running over all goods
and all households,
including, actually, the
own terms, i i terms,
as if assigning to your
goods to themselves.
Anyway.
Then we have-- if we're going
to solve the Pareto problem,
we have the typical
constraint over here
that if household i
is consuming good k,
and we sum up
overall households,
we'll get the total amount
of good k being allocated
like a resource constraint.
But in addition,
we would have that
what household j
experiences in terms of what
i is eating of household--
of good k, whatever household
i is doing of good k,
it's impacting household j
and all the other households.
So xik, this guy here,
what i is really doing of k
is what j experiences that
i is doing of k over all
the other households j.
So this is an externality,
you could think, positively
or negatively inflicted on
all the other households.
Whatever household i is
doing, it as consequences
for all the other households.
Well anyway, it looks like
a standard Pareto problem.
We could maximize
lambda-weighted sums
of utilities and we would have
these two resource constraints,
17 being conventional,
but 18 being
the new thing that we need.
So let's think
about shadow prices.
This guy here, 17, is going to
produce a Lagrange multiplier
for every good k.
So we can call that qk.
This guy here, 18, is going to
produce a Lagrange multiplier
for every j because there--
j goes from 1 to n
for every household i
and for every good k.
So there's lots of
Lagrange multipliers
and we can call them Pijk
for all these constraints.
These are shadow prices.
These are going to be the
shadow prices of the rights.
And with these
shadow prices, we're
going to be able to
decentralize to get
to Pareto-optimal
competitive equilibrium.
If you looked at the
first-order conditions,
where does jik enter?
It enters into the
utility function of j.
There's a lambda j for the
Pareto weight of household j,
because we'd be maximizing
lambda-weighted sums
of utilities in
the Pareto problem.
And where else does xjik enter?
It enters here.
So then we pick up
that Pijk Lagrange
multiplier because
everything else is linear.
So that's where
this is coming from.
And then this second first-order
comes from going back
to look at the xik.
Now the xik appears here
in 17, so we pick up
the conventional Lagrange
multiplier there.
But that xik also enters into
a multitude of constraints here
on 18, namely one
for each of the j's.
So we have a Pijk down
here, summing over all those
because it appears in each
and every one of them,
and that's this expression.
So there's our price system.
We have a conventional
price system
qk for each of the underlying
goods, but in addition to that,
we have these price of
rights to assign consumption
for other households.
And I deleted the
rest of the slides
because this is the intuition.
It's enough.
You've already seen us take
prices as Lagrange multipliers
and decentralize.
You can write down the
problem of the household
and the decentralized
problem with these prices
through the Lagrangian,
take the derivatives,
and you will get these
expressions back.
So that's the way we
proved the second welfare
theorem, that any Pareto-optimal
allocation can be achieved.
Now there's a lot of
externalities here.
Where did they all go?
The answer is we created
a market in all the goods.
Another way to view this
on the production side
is that when a household
is deciding what to eat,
it is aware of the utility
consequences and also
the expense in the budget.
But it's also getting
revenue, because it's
producing the jik goods that the
other households j care about.
So it's like as a firm, it's
selling those for revenue,
which is kind of like combining
the examples that we've had
so far.
OK.
So let me get to the
failure of the first welfare
theorem in a different way.
Instead of having
missing markets,
I'm going to have
too many markets.
An infinite number of goods.
So you may remember how the
proof went of the first welfare
theorem, but just in case,
I'll review it for you.
So the first welfare
theorem was that
any competitive equilibrium
would be Pareto-optimal.
We did it by contradiction.
We said no.
Suppose it were
not Pareto-optimal,
then this baseline x allocation
would be weakly dominated
for some households, the
baseline would be the star.
The alternative is
without the star.
So the dominating one weakly
dominates for some households
and strictly
dominates for others
relative to the baseline.
And then we kind
of did this algebra
and decided that clearly for
the households for which this
dominates, it would
not be affordable.
We used a lemma that even for
the households for which they
would be indifferent, it
costs at least as much.
We then add it up over
all the households
and got that the
value of expenses
in the alternative, suppose
Pareto-dominating allocation
is strictly greater than
the valuation of expenses
in the baseline of the
competitive equilibrium.
And then using that fact along
with the other conditions,
we ended up--
the bottom line
of the proof was,
this alternative allocation
was not feasible,
because we had this inequality
strictly greater than 0
going on here.
But the alternative
Pareto-dominating allocation
is supposed to be
feasible, so this
would be the contradiction.
Now it all seems
pretty straightforward,
but what happens if there's an
infinite number of households?
We start summing up
over infinity here.
It has no meaning that--
not necessarily
having a meaning.
If it's infinity,
greater than infinity,
well that's where the logic
of the proof breaks down.
You can't have one infinity
being bigger than another one.
So this can happen in
overlapping generations
models where we have
a first generation,
a second generation,
a third one,
and it goes on without end.
Everyone has a finite life, but
the economy goes on forever.
So how many goods are there?
An infinite number of goods?
How many households are there?
An infinite number
of households.
As an example, but
this isn't exactly
overlapping generations,
it's very much in that spirit
and it's easier to
understand what goes
wrong with the welfare theorem.
Let's just outright have an
infinite number of agents
and only two goods, 1 and 2.
Each household has an endowment
of each of the two goods,
1 unit of the first and
1 unit of the second.
Each household i also has
a common utility function,
which is this log utility.
Additive Cobb-Douglas.
So let's call the price
vector of the two goods
p1, p2, let the first would be
the numeraire, second one have
a relative price of p.
You may remember that these
Cobb-Douglas-like utility
functions generate
constant expenditures.
So p, the price of
the second good,
times the quantity
of the second good
is equal to 1/2
of the endowment,
because the weights here
are equal on the two goods.
Endowment, they have the
first good at a price of 1, 1
unit of the second
good at a price of p.
So one half of the
valuation of their endowment
is spent on good 2,
1/2 is spent on good 1.
These are the demand
equations at prices p.
What's a possible solution here?
Well, let's try p equal to 1.
If the price of the second
good was equal to 1,
then the solution to these
equations are x1 and x2
is equal to 1.
1/2 of 1 plus 1, et cetera.
So that is a candidate--
autarky, actually--
equilibrium and price is p,
they choose not to trade.
If the welfare
theorem were true,
then that competitive
equilibrium
should be Pareto-optimal,
but it's not.
Why not?
OK, now I'm going to pull
this rabbit out of my hat.
It's kind of amazing.
Let's have the second household
transfer all of its endowment
to the first one.
The first one started out with
1, 1, now he gets to 2, 2.
And you say, oh,
this guy's 0, 0.
No, no, no, no.
So household 2 gets
compensated from household 3.
Transfers his or her
endowment to household 2.
Household 2 is no
worse than before.
Household 1 is better off.
If we had a finite
number of households,
the last guy would get screwed.
But this goes on forever,
so you can dominate.
You're like pulling this
good out of infinity.
Another way to
say this is what's
happening to the
welfare theorem?
As I said, what we need is,
even with an infinite number
of goods, that the
valuation over all
of them, over all the
households is a real number.
For the proof to
go through, it has
to dominate the valuation
of the endowment.
We need to be able to
evaluate the endowments
in an infinite good economy,
and in that equilibrium
and autarky, the valuation
of wealth is infinite.
Why?
Because we have the endowment
of household 1 i equal 1, 1.
The price equal 1, 1.
So this dot-product is 1, 2--
sorry.
And we add up to overall the
households and we get infinity.
So the valuation of wealth
in that very special economy
was infinite, and that's
why the proof broke down.
You could see that it broke
down because we dominated
the supposed
Pareto-optimal autarky
allocation by something better.
Now when we go to an
infinite horizon model,
something like
this could happen,
because we've got an
infinite number of goods.
Even without
overlapping generations,
if we imagine
households live forever,
like in a medieval storage
economy or whatever-- well,
that's not--
they died every 13 years.
But with an infinite
dimensional commodity space,
it could be that the valuation
of wealth is infinite
and competitive equilibrium
would not be Pareto-optimal.
However, typically those prices
are declining at rate beta,
and beta's the discount
rate and utility.
So you have an infinite
sum, but that infinite sum
converges to something finite
as we add more and more terms.
So that's why this
doesn't always happen.
The necessary and sufficient
condition is this one, 23.
So decision time.
I'm going to skip
the last five slides.
I will tell you what
the content of it
is, which is a bit frustrating,
because I don't have time
to go over it.
I anticipated this thinking
about the lecture this morning,
there's a lot of material here.
But this is the starred
paper on the reading list.
So between these five
slides and that paper,
you should be able
to understand.
The economics of this
problem is, what do I
get from owning Bitcoin?
Hopefully I have the right to
buy things from someone else,
but only if they want the coin.
So my problem is
defined as in a network.
If I'm a buyer, I want sellers.
If I'm a seller, I want buyers.
My utility is a consequence of
who else is on the platform,
whether it's a cryptocurrency
platform or something else.
So there's a natural
externality here
that these households
care about who else
is populating the platform.
You would think
with an externality,
competitive equilibrium
is going to go bad
and we're not going to
get to a Pareto optimum,
but there is a
remedy, and that is
to price the right to
participate in the platform
according to your
agent utility type.
So different types
pay different amounts.
They buy the rights to
participate on the platform,
and that's going to
internalize the externality,
much in the same
way that we were
talking about with
pollution rights and so on.
But anyway, I'm
already a minute over.
So I'm going to
skip these slides.
You can take a look at them.
And if you have questions, maybe
we can talk a little bit more
about it next time.
And that's all for today.